Um, okay. Hey, everyone looks
like we're on a, so as usual,
if you have not yet,
um,
please enter your suid so that
we know you're here in this room.
Um, so I should compete for him.
He, okay. The back is it okay?
Oh yes. Is the volume okay? Are the
back all right? No one's responding.
Yes. Okay. All right.
Thank you. Okay, so, um,
what are the ones to do today
is share a you two things.
You know,
we're approaching the end of the course.
There are a hope you guys looking
forward to the Thanksgiving break. Um,
next week, um, Ashley and I
guess we were La home viewers,
but those of us does do that.
Viewing this from outside California.
I know that we're all feeling really bad
air here in California. I said, Whoa,
there's some of you are watching this at
home yet. That's a air wherever you are.
Um, uh, but um,
well to do today is give you some advice
that will set you up for the future of
stuff.
Even beyond the conclusion of cs two 30
and in particular one on one to do today
is share with view some advice on
how to read research papers. Uh,
because you know,
deep down is evolving fast enough
that even though you've learned law,
the foundations of deep learning,
I learned a lot of the tips and tricks
then you probably know better than many
practitioners. How's it as you can do
going out rooms to work already. Um,
when you're working on specific
applications where doing comms division on
national falsing let's be
recognition or something else, um,
for you to be able to efficiently figure
out the academic literature on key
parts of the deep learning world will
help you keep on developing and you know,
staying on top of ideas
even as they evolve over the
next several years or maybe
decades. So firstly we want to do
is, um, give you advice on how, uh,
when say when I'm trying to
master a new body of literature,
how I go about that and hope that those
techniques will be useful to help you be
more efficient. How you
read research papers. Um,
and then the second thing is in
previous offerings of this cost,
one request from a lot of students was
just advice for navigating a career in
machine learning.
And so in the second half of today,
I want to share some thoughts
with you on that. Okay. Um,
so it turns out that,
so I guess too is how pigs meeting
besides papers, right? And, um,
and then second career advice in
machine learning. So turns out that,
um,
okay.
You know,
reading besides papers,
this one of those things that a lot of
phd students learn via Osmosis, right?
Meaning that if you're a phd
student and you see, you know,
a few professors will see other phd
students do sorts of the things that he
might try to pick it up by Osmosis.
But I hope today to a celebrate your
efficiency and how you acquiring all this
yourself from DOL, from the
academic literature. Right?
And so, um, then I say that this
an area you want to become good at.
Let's say you want to build that
speech recognition. Alright,
just turns it off for now. Let's
see. You want to build that to him?
Speech recognition system that we
talked about it cause they're Robert's,
her and all. And then the desk lamp,
right? Um, this is what I read.
There's a sequence of steps I
recommend you take on, which is first
Kampala, this papers. Um, and uh, and,
and by papers I mean both research
papers often posted on archive,
on the Internet, but also
plus medium pose. Um,
okay.
Yeah, Wah. Maybe some okays get helped
poses though those are rare raw. Uh,
but whatever texts or learning
resources you have. And then, um,
what I usually do is end up
skipping around in this, right?
So if I'm trying to master
a new body of knowledge,
so you want learn about
speech recognition systems,
this is what it feels like
to read a set of papers,
which is maybe you initially
start off with five papers.
And if on the horizontal axis I plot,
you know,
0% to 100% red slash.
Understood, right? Um,
the way it feels like reading these
papers is often I'll read, you know,
10% of each paper or I try to quickly
skim and understanding each of these
papers. And if based on that you
decide that paper number two is a dud,
right? Other, other, other
authors, even Satan and say, boy,
they sure they show it wrong, will you
be there? It just doesn't make sense.
Then go ahead and forget it. And as you
skip around to different papers, uh,
you might decide that paper
three is they're really
seminar one and then spend a
lot of time to go ahead and read
and understand the whole thing.
And based on that,
you might then find a six paper from the
citations and read that and go back and
flesh or your understanding of paper for,
and then find the paper seven and go and
read that all the way to the conclusion.
Um, but this is what it
feels like as you, you know,
assemble and lists of papers and skipping
around and they try to, um, uh, uh,
monster, a body of literature right
around some topic that you want to learn.
And I think, um, some
rough guidelines, you know,
if Your View 50th to 20 papers, I think
you have a basic understanding of a,
of an area, right? So let me, I was
like maybe good enough to do some work,
apply some algorithms.
Um,
if you read 50 to a hundred papers in
an area like speech recognition and,
and kind of understanding a lot of it,
then that's part of the enough to give
you a very good understanding of an area.
Right? You, you might,
I don't know, I'm, I,
I'm as careful about when I say
like you mastering a subject,
but you're beat 50 a hundred
papers on speech recognition.
You had a very good understanding,
uh, speech recognition. Oh,
if you're interested in say,
domain at that station, right?
By the time you've read
50 or a hundred papers,
do you have a very good understanding of,
of a subject like that?
But they read five to 20 papers. It's
probably enough for you to implement it,
but maybe not,
not sure if there's enough for you to
do research or be really at the cutting
edge.
But these are maybe some guidelines for
the volume of reading you should aspire
to if you want to pick up a new area.
But I'll take one association and cs two
30 and go more deeply into it. Right.
Um,
no.
How do you read one paper? And, um, I
hope most of you brought your laptop.
So what I'm going to do is describe to
you how I read one paper and then after
that I'm actually going to ask all of you
to, you know, download the paper online.
They just take, I'll know, uh,
uh, take, take a few minutes of,
read a paper right here in class and
see how far you can get understanding of
research paper in just minutes.
Right, right here in class. Okay. Um,
so when reading one paper,
so the bad way to read the paper is to
go from the first word until the last
word, right. This is a bad way to when
you want, you have a paper like this. Oh,
and by the way, Ashley here and tell
you what my real life is like. So, um,
I actually pretty much everywhere I go,
whenever I backpack,
this is my actual fo there.
Um, I don't want to show,
this is my actual folder of unread paper.
So pretty much everywhere I go,
I actually have a paper, a stack of
papers is on my personal reading lists.
This is actually my real life.
I didn't bring this to show you.
This isn't like that pat all the time.
Uh, and I think that, I don't know,
these days I'm on my team
at landing Ain t blinder AI.
I personally lead in reading group where
I lead a discussion about two papers a
week.
Uh,
but to select two papers and means I need
to eat like five or six papers a week
to select to, you know, to present or
discuss at the [inaudible] meeting group.
So this is my real life.
Right?
And how I tried to stay on top
of the pitcher show and I have a,
I'm doing a lot if I can find this fine,
if I can find the time to beat, you know,
a couple of papers will be
hopefully all of you can to, um, uh,
but when I'm reading a paper,
this is,
this is how I would
recommend you go about it,
which is don't go from the first or,
and they read until the last word. Um,
instead up tick multiple
passes through the paper.
Right. Um, and so, you know, step one is a
we the title,
the abstract
and also the figures. Um,
especially in the deep learning,
there are a lot of research papers where
stuff, the entire paper is summarize it,
one or two fingers and they
figure captions. So, um,
so sometimes just by reading
the title abstract and you know,
the key neural network architecture
figure that just describes what the whole
papers out and maybe one or
two of the experiments section,
you can sometimes get a very good sense
of what the whole paper is about without
hardly reading any of the texts
in their pay for itself. Right?
That's the first pass.
Second Pass.
I would tend to read more carefully
the intro to conclusions.
Um,
look carefully at all the fingers again
and then skim the rest. And you know,
um, I don't know how many of you are
publish academic papers, but, uh,
when people publish academic
papers, um, part of, you know,
the publication process is convincing
the reviewers that your paper is worthy
for a sentence.
And so what you find is that the abstract
ensuring conclusion is often when the
authors tried to summarize
their work really,
really carefully to make a case to make
a really clear case to the review as to
why they think their paper should
be accepted for publication.
And so because of that,
you know,
maybe slightly not
slightly unusual incentive,
the intro and conclusion and abstract
often give a very clear summary of what's
the paper actually about.
Um, and depending on,
um,
and again,
just be bluntly honest with you guys.
Um,
the related work section is useful
if you want. It's sometimes useful.
You want to do understand related
work and figure out what's,
what are the most important
works in the papers.
But the first time you read this you
might skim or even skip skim the related
work section. And it turns out, unless
you're already from early literature,
if this is a body of net worth that
you're not that familiar with the related
work section is sometimes almost
impossible to understand. Uh, and again,
since I'm being very honest with you guys,
sometimes the related work section is
when the authors tried to say everyone
that could possibly be reviewing the
paper and to make them a few good and then
hopefully accepted paper if it's a related
work sections and sometimes written
in funny ways, right? Um, and then, uh,
set three.
I would often read the paper,
but I'm just skip the math.
Right. Um, and for wheat, the whole thing,
but skip pass,
it don't make sense,
you know? Um, I think that uh,
one thing that's happened many
times in their research is that,
I mean the papers,
we tend to be cutting edge research.
And so when we publish things,
we sometimes don't know what's really
important. It was not important. Right?
So there,
there are many examples of well known,
highly cited research papers,
whereas some of it was just great stuff.
And some of it, you know,
turned out to be unimportant.
But at the time to paypal has written,
the authors did not know every no one on
the planet knew what was important and
what was not important. And maybe one
example, um, the, the net five paper,
right sound, no paper by Yonder
Quinn, part of it was phenomenal.
We just established a
lot of the foundations of
continents. Uh, and so it was,
it one of the most incredibly
influential papers.
But you'd go back and read that paper
and another sort of Ho half of the paper
was about other stuff, right?
Transducers and so on. Dennis,
much less use and so and so is fine if
you read a paper and some of it doesn't
make sense because it's not that unusual.
Well sometimes it just happens that, um,
great research means we're
publishing things are the
boundaries of our knowledge.
And sometimes, uh, the
stuff you see, you know,
we'll realize five years in the future
that that wasn't the most important thing
off there. All right. Well that the,
what was the key part of the Ahhbra
maybe wasn't what the author's thought.
And so sometimes it pops paper don't make
sense is okay to skip it initially and
move on. Right? So, uh, unless
you're trying to do a peak,
unless you're trying to do the research
and really you need to master it,
then go ahead and spend more time.
But they're trying to get through a lot
of the papers then, you know, then Dennis,
just prioritizing your
time. Okay. Um, and so,
uh,
just a few
last things and then I'll
ask you to practice this
yourself with a paper, right.
Um, you know, I think that when
you've read and understood the paper,
okay.
Decent questions to try to keep
in mind and when you eat a paper,
then a few minutes maybe and
try to answer these questions.
One thing you also has
tried to accomplish,
why the hope to do in a few minutes is
asking you to download the paper off the
Internet. We did. And then, um,
try to answer these questions and discuss
your answer to these questions with,
with your peers. Read with
others in the class. Okay. Um,
okay.
What were the key elements?
Okay.
What can you use yourself and,
um,
okay.
Okay. So I think of you
can answer these questions.
Hopefully that will reflect that you
have a pretty good understanding of the
paper. Okay. Um,
and so what I would like you
to do is pull up your laptop.
And then, so you know, there's actually
a, so I think on the confident videos,
right on the Dev land,
our AI concept videos and Coursera,
you learned a bit about um,
uh,
various neural network architectures up
to it resonates and it turns out that
there's another,
a follow on piece of work.
There may be builds on some
of the ideas of resonance,
which is called dense nets. So
what I'd like you to do is, um, oh,
and so when did I can do is actually try
this and when I'm reading a paper again
in the earliest stages,
don't get stuck on the map.
Just go ahead and skim the math and the
English texts we get through faster. Uh,
and maybe one of the principles is go
from the very efficient high information
content for us and then go
to the harder material later.
It is why often now just skimmed a map.
And I don't,
if I don't understand
the similar integration,
just move on and then they'll
only data go back and,
and really try to figure out
the map more carefree. Okay.
So one of the lecture they do is take
on a, why don't you take, um, uh,
uh, winter of uh, let's,
let's, let's try it. Let's,
let's have you take seven minutes
where I'm thinking maybe one,
one minute per occasion,
quite fast.
And search for this paper,
densely connected.
Convolutional neural net, net
works by
Warhol as Oh, okay. Why should
I stick out your laptops?
A searcher. This paper, a download,
it is refined is on archive.
Um, ar XIV. Right. And uh, and it,
this is also something that you
also called his dense net. So yes.
Um, and go ahead and take, why
don't you take like seven minutes?
So we just paper and I'll let you
know when the time has passed.
And then after that time,
um, I liked you to, you know,
discuss with your, with the
others, right. What, what,
what you think are the answers,
especially in the first two,
because the other two you can leave off.
Why don't you go ahead and take a few
minutes to do that now and then I'll let
you know when,
um,
so the like seven minutes of pass and
then you can discuss your answers with
these with your friends.
Okay. All right guys. So,
um,
anyone with any thoughts or insights
or surprises or thoughts from this?
So now you've spent 11
minutes on this paper, right?
Seven minutes of eating for minutes.
Discussing is really,
really short period of time. But any,
any thoughts or do you think of the paper
going, you're, you're just spending lots
of counseling, offsetting each other.
W W what do people think of the time
you spend trying to read the paper?
Actually they should tell you how I
should raise your hand if you, a few of,
you know, you kind of understood the
main concepts in the camper just a bit,
2000 linear feet
and actually requesting to the figures.
Okay.
Wow. People are really less than average,
I think today than usual. Everyone.
So I think this is one of
those papers where, um, the,
the paper is almost, it's
how you summarize, uh,
figures one and two,
right?
I think if you got to see a lot of people
now if you look at figure of one and
the caption the
on page three and the caption there
and understand those two figures,
those really convey, you know, 80%
of the idea of the paper. All right.
Um, and I think that uh, um,
a couple of other tips. So, um,
it turns out that as you read
these papers, what practice
you do get faster. So,
um, for example, table
one a on page four, right?
You know,
this mess of a table on top,
this is a pretty common format or a format
like this is how a lot of authors use
to distract a network architecture,
especially in computer vision.
So one of the things that
you find as well is that, um,
the first time you see
something like Table One,
it just looks really complicated.
But by the time you've read a few
papers in the similar format, you build,
look at Table One, then go, oh,
Yep, got it. Yeah, this is, this is,
this is the dentist at one 21%,
just one 69 architecture.
And be with them more quickly.
Pick up those things.
And so another thing you find is that
I'm meeting these papers actually gets
better with practice because you see
different authors use different ways on
some of the ways of expressing themselves
and the kids used to that you guys
should be faster and faster at
implementing these, um, at, at,
at understanding these ideas.
And I think these days we're not reading
a paper like this and maybe it takes me
about half an hour to two if you'd like.
And I,
I know I gave you guys seven minutes
when I thought I would need maybe half an
hour to figure out a people like this.
Uh, um, uh, and I think, uh, for a more,
I find that a,
it's not unusual for people,
relatively new to machine learning to
maybe an hour to kind of, you know,
really understand that paper like this.
Um,
and then I'll know I'm pretty experienced
machine learning and some downs have
maybe half an hour for people like this,
maybe even 20 minutes.
It was a really easy one, but there are
some outliers, so I have some colleagues,
so sometimes it stumped by crowds
are really difficult paper.
You need to chase a lot of
references and then love on this now.
So sometimes you come across a paper that
takes you three or four hours or even
longer to really understand it. But, uh,
but I think depending on how much
time do you want to spend probate,
reading papers, um, you could
actually learn, you know,
learn a lot rights, um, uh,
doing what you just did,
but maybe spending half an opera paper
and our paper rather than seven minutes.
Right. Um, so, all right.
I feel like, uh, yeah, it was,
and notice that I've actually not said
anything about the content of this paper,
right? So whatever you guys
just learned, that was all you,
I had nothing to do with it.
So you know that y'all have the ability
to go and learn this stuff by yourself.
You don't need me anymore.
Right.
So just a last few comments.
Um,
let's see. So the other few can, he'd ask
questions I get is, uh, you know, where,
where do you go?
The deep learning a few of evolves so
rapidly. So where, where do you go to?
So if you're trying to master
a new body of knowledge,
definitely do web searches and they're
often good blog posts on the, oh,
she had the most important
papers in speech recognition.
There are lots of great resources there.
And then the other thing you,
I don't know,
love people try one to do is try to
keep up with the state of yard of deep
learning even as it's evolving rapidly.
And so I just tell you
where I go to keep up with,
um, you know, discussions, announcements,
a surprising the Twitter is becoming
an surprisingly important place for
researchers to find out about new things.
Um,
there's a m l sub reddit is
actually pretty good. Um,
lots of noise for many important
pieces of where do get mentioned there.
Some of the top machine learning
conferences are nips ICML
and I clear. All right. Uh, and so
whenever these conferences come around,
take a look and glance
through at least the title,
see if it's something that interests you.
And then I think, unfortunately, I guess,
um, friends, you know, um, uh, both
colleagues here at Stanford as,
as colleagues to several of the
teams I work with that um, uh, uh,
that, just tell me where
there's a cool paper I guess,
but I think with here with in
Stanford or among your workplace,
for those of you taking this NSTP
DDP and form a community that shares
interesting papers.
So lot of the groups I have are on
slack and we regularly slack each other.
I'll send, send each other a text
messages on the slack messaging system.
We find interesting papers that,
that's been great for me actually. Um,
yeah. Oh, and, and
Twitter. Let's see. Ken Is,
I follow Keon you could follow him to,
this is me,
Andrew wine, right. Um, I prayed on
slack or papers as often as I do,
but if you look at, I don't know, you
can also look at who we follow them.
There are a lot of good researchers
that then we'll share all these things
online. And um, there,
there's a bunch of people,
they also use a website
called archive sanity. Um, I
don't ask much sometimes, um,
but, but loss of resources
like that. Great. Um,
cool.
So just two last tips for
how to be papers in good,
good at this.
Um,
so it's a more deeply understand the
paper. Some of the papers will have
math in it and actually if Vieta I'll
know y'all learned about bashing.
All right. And uh, um, a
second module is videos.
If you read the bashing on paper is
actually one of the harder papers he read.
Um, uh, there's a lot of math
in the derivation of bashed. No,
but their papers like that. And if you
want to make sure you understand the math,
here's what I would recommend,
which is a read through it,
take detailed notes and then see if
you can read, derive it from scratch.
So if you want to deeply understand the
math of an algorithm, like, you know,
fashion or more the details
of backdrop or something. Um,
the good practice and I
think a lot of, um, uh, uh,
sort of a theory, a thorough company,
signs and mathematics PhD students,
we use a practice ideas which
just go ahead and read the paper,
make sure you understand it. And
then to Mitchell, you really,
really understand it.
Put a p,
put aside the results and try to re
derive the math yourself from scratch.
And if you can start from a blank piece
of paper and read derived one of these
algorithms and stretch. And that's a
good side and you really understood it.
When I was a phd student, I did this
a lot, right? Um, that, you know,
I would read a textbook or read the
paper or something and then put aside
whether I read and see if I could read
the revive it from scratch starting from
a blank piece of paper as only
if I could do that. Did I,
would you have a few like, Yep. I think
I understand this piece of math. Um,
and it turns out if you want me
to do this type of map yourself,
is your ability to derive
this type of math redirect,
this type of math that gives
you the ability to generalize,
to derive new novel
pieces of math yourself.
So I think I actually learned the after
math of several machine learning by
doing this and this by the riving other
people's work that allowed me to learn
how to divide my own novel algorithms.
And actually sometimes you go
to the art galleries, right?
They go to the Smithsonian, you see,
these aren't students, you know,
sitting on the floor.
I'm copying the great artworks,
the great paintings painted by
the masses so centuries ago.
And so I think just as a today,
there are students sitting in or the
de Young Museum or whatever, every or,
and I was at the Getty Museum
in La a few months ago.
You actually see these aren't citizens,
you know, copying the work or the masters.
And I think a lot of the ways that
you want to become good at the math of
machine learning yourself, uh, this
is, this is a good way to do it.
It's time consuming, but then you
can become good at it that way.
And same thing for cones
rates. I think the, um, simple,
lightweight version one of learning would
be to download and run to open source
code if you can find it.
And a deeper way to learn this
material is to reimplement it scratch,
right?
It's easy to download an open source
thing and rather than this, Ooh, it works.
But if you can implement one
of these albums from scratch,
then that's a strong scientist you've
really understood. Does Alfred. Okay.
Um, all right. And then
longer term advice,
right?
You know, you'd say keep on learning
and keep on getting better and better.
The more important thing is
for you to learn steadily,
not for you to have a focus, intense
activity. You know, like, uh,
all the Thanksgiving you read 50 papers
over Thanksgiving and then you're done
for the rest of your life. It
doesn't work like that. Right.
And I think you actually much better our
reading to a few papers a week for the
next year then,
you know,
cramming everything right over over
one long weekend or something. Oh,
actually in education we're actually known
in the space repetition where I sweat
in the traveling. So, uh, the same,
same thing, same body of learning.
If you learn a bit every
week and space it out,
you actually have much
better long term retention.
Then you try to cram everything
in the short term. So does,
does a very solid result that we know
from pedagogy and how the human brain
world. So, so if you're able
to, um, so, so again, the way I,
my life is my backpack.
I just always have a few papers with me.
I'm going to find that again.
I've read almost everything on the tablet,
on almost everything on an iPad,
but they find that research papers and
all those things where the ability to
flip the team pages and skim, I still
find more efficient on paper. So, um,
I read almost nothing on paper these
days except for research papers.
But that's just me. Your mileage may vary.
Maybe something else will work. Okay.
All right. Um, so let's see.
That's if I read a recent papers,
I hope that while you're in
CSU 30, you know, by the way,
if some of you find some cool papers,
I've you have,
go further for the dense that paper and
find an interesting result there. Um,
go ahead and post on Piazza or if any
of you want to solve their reading group
of other friends here at Stanford, you
know, encourage you to look around class,
fine,
fine.
Finally group here on campus or
among your CSU 30 classmates,
what were,
we were all of your work colleagues for
those of you taking this on their CPD so
that you can all keep,
you know,
studying to so that you're sharing and
learning and helping each other along.
Okay. Um, so that's it
for reading papers. Uh,
the second thing want to do today is
just give some longer term advice on
navigating a career in, in,
in machine learning. Right.
Any questions about this before I move on?
Okay, cool. All right.
But I hope that was useful.
Some of this I wish I had no when I was
a first year phd student, but we'll see.
All right. Um, let's see.
Can we turn on the lights
please? All right. All right.
So kind of in response to
requests from earlier citizen
earlier versions of the
clause before we, you know,
as we approach the end of the quarter one,
so it gives some advice,
the housing navigator career
machine learning, right? So, uh,
today machine learning,
there are so many opportunities to do so
many exciting things. So, um, how do you,
you know, what, what, what
do you want to do? Um,
so I'm going to assume that,
um,
most of you will want to do one of
two things, right? At some point,
you know, you want to,
um, get the job right.
Maybe a job that does
work in machine learning,
including a faculty position for those
of you who I've been a professor.
But I guess eventually most people
end up with a job I think. Right?
I guess there are other alternatives but,
oh,
but then some of you want to go on to
more advanced graduate studies and it,
although even after you
get your phd at some point,
most people do get the job after
the Phd. Um, and, and, and by job,
I mean, uh, either in the
big company, you know,
or as, or a startup, right?
But regardless of the details of this,
I think,
I hope most of you wants
to do important work.
Cool.
Great. So, um,
what I like to do today is break,
you know this into how's he find a
job or join a phd program or whatever.
I then lets you do important work and I
want to break this discussion into two
steps. One is just, you know,
how, how do you get that position,
right?
How do you get that job off pharaoh?
How do you get that offer of
admissions in a PhD program? Oh,
meshes in the master's program or
whatever you want to do. Um, and then two,
is that selecting a position?
Okay,
right. Have a teen, you know,
going to this university
of has that university or
which in taking on the job in
this company for that company,
what are the ones that will tend to set
you up for success for long term crystal
success and career success? Uh, and,
and really I hope that by the way,
I hope that all of these, I just tactics
to let you do important work, right?
I know these, I hope that's
what you want to do. Um,
so you know what the recruiters look for.
Oh. And I think just to
keep the language simpler,
I'm going to pretend that I'm just
going to talk about finding a job.
But a lot of the very similar
things apply for PHD programs.
It's just instead of saying recruiters,
I would say admissions committees, right?
Then it's actually,
some of this is,
this is they've just
focused on the job scenario.
So most recruiters love
for technical skills. Uh,
so for example, um, there are a
lot of, um, uh, machine learning.
They'll ask you questions
like, you know, well,
would you use grid into sands or
bachelor and sand? The, the consequences,
our bachelor's and what happens in the
batch size is too large or too small,
right?
So there are companies,
many companies today asking questions
like that in the interview process. Uh,
Oh, can you explain? There was an LCM
and the Gru and where would you use on?
So you really get questions like
that in many job interviews today.
And so recruits is looking for ml skills,
uh,
as well as,
and so you often be quizzed on
ml skills as well as our, um,
your coding ability. Right?
Um, and then beyond your,
and, and I think Silicon Valley has
become quite good at giving people the
assessments to test for real
skill in machine learning,
engineering and software engineering.
Um,
and then the other thing
they're recruiters will look
for that many recruiters
will look for is a meaningful work.
And in particular, um,
uh, you know, they're all,
some candidates that apply for
jobs that have very, um, uh,
theoreticals.
They're very academic skills.
Meaning you can answer all
the quiz questions about,
you know, what is bash norm,
can you,
they're arguing December this,
but unless you've actually show him
that you can apply this and meaningful
setting, it's harder to convince a
company or recruiter that, you know,
not just a theory but they, you know, how
to actually make this stuff work. And so,
um, having done meaningful work using
machine learning is a very strong,
it's a very desirable candidate,
I think to a lot of companies
kind of work experience.
And I think really whether you've done,
whether you've done something meaningful,
um, reassures that you know, that
you can actually do work right.
It's not just economic quiz questions,
but you know how to implement during
the algorithms that work. Um, and, and,
and maybe, um, uh, yeah.
Um, and in many recruiters actually look
for your ability to keep on learning new
skills and stay on top of machine learning
and even see you've asked as well.
And so a very common pattern
for the, um, successful,
you know,
AI engineers say machine
learning engineers would be
the following where on the
horizontal axis I applied
to different areas.
So you might learn about machine learning,
learn about deep learning,
learn about probabilistic
graphical models, learn about NLP,
learn about computer vision and so on for
other areas of Ai and machine learning.
Um, and if the vertical
area, if the vertical axis is
death,
a lot of the strongest candidate,
so jobs are t shaped individuals,
meaning that you have a
broad understanding of many
different topics in the AI
and machine learning and very
deep understanding in, you know,
maybe at least one area, maybe
more than one the area. Um,
and so I think by taking assist two
30 and doing the things you're doing,
if you're a,
hopefully you're acquiring
a deeper understanding of
one of these areas of deep
learning in particular. Um, but the
other thing that, uh, even, you know,
uh, deepens their knowledge in one
area will be the projects you work on,
the open source contributions
you make, right? Uh,
whether or not you've done search,
um,
and maybe whether or not
you've done an internship.
And I think these two elements,
you know,
broad area of skills and then also going
deeper to do a meaningful project and
deep learning or work of a
Stanford professor, right? Oh,
and do a meaningful
research project or a mix,
some contributions to open
source publishing like Github
and there, let's use it.
These are the things that you deepen your
knowledge and convince recruiters that
you both have the broad technical
schools and when called on,
you're able to apply these in a,
in a,
in a meaningful way to an important
problem, right? And in fact, um,
the way we design cs two 30 is
actually a microcosm of this where,
um, you know, you learned about
neuro nets, um, learn about topics.
They're bashed norm confidence,
a sequence models, right?
And just say rns.
So actually have a breath within
the field of deep learning.
And then what happens is no then,
and the reason why is you to work on the
project is so that you can pick one of
these areas and maybe go deep and build
a meaningful project and one of these
areas, uh, which will, which war. And it's
not just about making a resume look good,
right?
This is about giving you the practical
experience to make sure you actually know
how to make these things work, um, uh,
and give you the learnings to make sure
that you actually know how the make of
CNN work. You look at
our and then work. Uh,
and then coincidentally the many students
also this depression and the resume's
obviously. Um, so I think the, um,
let's see, the, the, the
failure modes, the things,
bad ways to navigate your career. Um,
there are some students that just do this,
right? There are some Stanford students
that just take class off the cost off the
costs,
off the clos,
and go equally in depth
in a huge range of areas.
And this is not terrible. You can actually
still get a job. Uh, uh, you know, so get,
sometimes you can even get into some
phd programs like this without the Def,
but this is not the best way
to navigate your career, right?
So there are some stem physicians who's,
that takes tons of classes.
You didn't get a good GPA doing that,
but do nothing else.
And this is not terrible,
but this is, this is not,
this is not great as it's not
as good as the alternative. Um,
there's one other thing I've seen
Stanford students do, which is, uh,
just try to do that,
right?
Which is just try to jump
in on day one and go really,
really deep in one area. And again, um,
this has its own challenges, I
guess. You know, one, one, one,
one failure mode. One mode is actually not
great. It's sometimes where she get, um,
uh,
undergrad freshmen at Stanford that have
not yet learned a lot about coding or
software and dream or machine learning
and tried to jump into research project
right away.
And this turns out not to
be very efficient because it
turns out Stanford Causes,
uh, you know, online
causes a Stanford closet.
There a very efficient way for you to
learn about the broad range of areas and
after that great deeper getting experience
in one vertical area then deepens
your knowledge and makes sure, you know,
how they actually meet those ideas work.
Uh, so I do see sometimes,
unfortunately, you know,
sent some Stanford freshman join us
already knowing how the code and have
implemented, you know,
some learning our rooms,
but some students that do not yet have
much experience tried to jump into
research project right away.
And that turns out not to
be very productive for the
student or for the research
group because until you've
taken the courses and mass,
the basics is difficult to understand
what's really going on at the advance
projects. Right. Um, so I would,
I would say this is actually worse than
that. Right. This is this is that, okay.
This is actually pretty bad. This is, I,
I will not do this for your career, right?
No, probably not. Yeah. Um,
and then the other not so great mode that
you see some San business do is get a
lot of breath and then do a tiny project
here and do a tiny project there.
I do a tiny project there,
do a tiny project there and you end up
with 10 tiny projects but no one or two
really significant project.
Cause then again this is not terrible,
but you know,
beyond a certain point by the way
recruiters and not impressed by volume.
Right? So having done 10 lane
projects is actually not impressive,
not nearly as impressive as doing one
great project or two great projects.
And again, there's more to life
than impressing recruiters,
but recruits is very rational.
And the reason recruiters
are less impressed by someone
whose profile looks like
this,
it is because they're actually probably
factually less skilled and less able at
doing good work in machine
learning compared to someone that,
that has done their substantive
project and knows what it takes to see,
see the whole thing through. Does that
make sense? So when I say, you know,
recruiters more or less impressive
because they're actually quite rational in
terms of trying to understand
how good you are at, um, uh,
at, at, at doing important
work and building meaningful
AI systems. Can you sense,
um,
and so in terms of building up all the
horizontal piece and the vertical piece,
uh, this is what I recommend
to build the horizontal piece.
Love of this is about
building foundational skills.
And, um, it turns out coursework as
a very efficient way to do this. Uh,
you know, in, in, in these causes,
right? You know, various instructors,
Lakers where many of the
separate professors for the law,
the work and to organizing the content
and because efficient for you to learn
this material. Um, and then also reading
research papers, which we
just talked about having a
community will help you. Um,
and then that is often
a building a more deep
okay.
And relevant project [inaudible]
precious how to rather than,
so you know, if you want to build
a career at machine learning,
could be liquor in the eye.
Hopefully the project is something that's
relevant to cs or machine learning or
AI or deep learning. Um,
I do see, I don't know,
for some reason I feel like a surprisingly
large number of stamps ins I know are
the Stanford Don's true. And they spent
a lot of time on that, which is fine.
If you enjoy dancing, go have fun, don't
you? You don't need to work all the time.
So going,
joined a dance to or go on the overseas
exchange program and go hang out in
London and have fun. But those things
do not as directly contribute to this.
Right. Yeah, I know.
I think, I think in the earlier
version of this presentation, yeah.
Stairs walked away saying, Huh, you
know, Andrea says we should not have fun.
It should work all the time
and that's not the girl.
Um,
all right,
there is one.
All right.
Okay.
You know,
there is the,
okay,
Saturday morning problem,
which all of you will face,
which is every week,
uh,
including this week on Saturday morning
you'll have a choice. Um, you can,
uh,
read the paper.
Okay.
What kind of research or working on open
source or I don't know why people do or
you could watch TV or something
and you were facing a choice
maybe every Saturday, you know,
for the rest of your life or for loss,
Adam days and the rest of your life. And,
um, you know, you can build
out that foundation skills,
go deep or go have fun and you should
have fun. All right, let's go the record.
But one of the problems that a lot of
people face is that even if you spend all
Saturday and all Sunday reading
a research paper, um, you know,
the following Monday or maybe spend
all Saturday and Sunday working hard,
it turns out that the following Monday
you're not that much better at deep
learning is like, yeah, you
work really. So you read five
papers, you know, great. Uh,
but if your work have a research
group, the professor or your, you know,
or your manager, if you're in the company,
they have no idea how hard you work.
So there's no one to come by and say,
Oh, good job working so hard all weekend.
So no one knows the sacrifices you may
all weekend to study or code open soles
in Poland is this,
no one knows.
So there's almost no short term
reward to doing these things. Um,
but the C and whereas they might be
short term rewards to doing other things.
Right. Um, uh,
but the secret to this is that it's
not about reading papers really,
really hot for one Saturday morning or
for all Saturday once and then being done.
The secret to this is to do this
consistently, um, you know, for years,
um,
or at least a month's.
And it turns out that if you read two
papers a week and you do that for a year,
then you will have read 50 papers after
a year and you will be much better at
teaching learning off of
that. Right? Uh, I mean,
when you read your read 100 papers in
the year of UV two papers a week and,
uh,
and so as,
so for you to be successful as much less
about the intense burst of effort you
put in over one weekend,
it's much more about whether you can
find a little bit of time every week to
read a few papers or crunch.
We have a bit of open source
or take someone I causes
AV, but, and if you do that,
you know, every week for six months,
so do that every week for a year,
you've will actually learned a lot about
these views and be much better and be
much more capable at deep learning or
machine learning or whatever. Right. Um,
yeah. So, um, yeah, and, but yeah,
it actually has essentially my,
my,
my wife and I actually do not own a
TV for what a soar. But again, if you,
if if you, oh my, go ahead. It's fine.
Make sure it don't, don't, don't,
don't drive yourself crazy. And the
healthy work life integration as well.
All right. So, um,
so I hope that doing these things well,
it's not about finding a job is about
doing these things to make you more
capable as a machine learning person
so that you have the power to garden,
implement stuff that matters to stuff
that you do, do work that matters.
Well, the second thing which
had about, is selecting a job
and it's actually really
interesting. Um, I, uh,
gave this part of the presentation,
um, last year, uh, actually, sorry,
earlier this year and shortly
after that presentation, um,
there was a student in the class,
there was already in a company who
emailed me saying, boy, Andrew,
I wish you had told me this before.
I said to my current job. Um,
so let's see. Let's see, let's see.
Hopefully this will be useful to you.
Um, so it turns out that, um,
uh, you know, so at some point
you're at, you're deciding, you know,
what phd problem do you wanna apply for?
What companies do want as
high for a job ads? And, um,
I can tell you what, uh, well,
so if you want to keep
learning new things, um,
I think one of the biggest predictors
of your success will be whether or not
you're working with great people
and projects.
Right?
And in particular, um, you
know, there, there are these
fascinating results from, uh,
uh, I think, I want to say from the
social sciences showing that, um,
if your closest friends,
if your five closest friends who are
10 closest friends are all smokers,
there isn't much high shine as you
become a smoker as well. Right?
And if you're five or 10 close
friends are, um, uh, uh, you know,
overweight as much high chance you would
do the same. Or conversely it does, uh,
um, you know, so I think that if your
five closest friends work really hard,
really long research papers,
care about their work, uh,
learning and making themselves better,
then that's actually a very
good chance that you will be,
that they'll influence you that
way as well. So we're all human.
We all influenced by the people
around us, right? And so, um,
I think that,
and I've been fortunate,
I've taught at Stanford
for a long time now. It's,
I've been fortunate to have seen a lot
of students go from Stanford to various
careers and because I've seen how many
hundreds or maybe low thousands of
Stanford students that I knew right
when there was still statuses go on to
separate job, I sold many of them have
amazing careers. Um, I saw, you know,
a few have like, like, okay careers. Um,
but I think over time I've learned to
pattern match what is predictive of your
future success after the staff.
And then we share with you somethings,
pat share with you some of those patterns
as you navigate your career. And, and,
and it's just, there's so many
options in machine learning today.
It's kind of tragic if you don't,
you know,
navigate to to hopefully maximize the
chance of being one of the people that
gets to do fun and important work
that helps, helps others. Um,
so when selecting a position,
um,
I would advice you to focus
on the team.
Um,
you interact with and by team I mean,
you know,
somewhere between 10 to 30 persons rent,
maybe up to 50. Um, because
it turns out that if, if,
if you, um, there will be some group
of people, maybe 10 to 30 people,
maybe 50 people that you
interact with quite closely,
and these will be your peers and the
people that influence you the most,
right? Um, because if you join
a company with 10,000 people,
you will not interact
with all 10,000 people.
There will be a core of 10 or 30 or 50
people that you interact with the most.
And is those people how much they know,
how much she didn't teach you,
how hardworking they are,
whether they are learning themselves that
will influence you the most rotted and
all these other hypothetical 10,000
people in the giant company. Um,
and of these people, one of the ones
that will influence you the most is uh,
your manager,
right?
So make sure you meet your manager and
get to know them and make sure there's
someone you want to work
with. Um, and in particular,
I would recommend focusing on
these things and not on the brand
of the company because it turns out that
the brand of the company you work with
is actually not that correlates it. Yeah,
maybe there's a very weak correlation,
but there's actually not that correlated
with what your personal experience will
be like. Oh, it makes
sense. Right? Um, and so,
um,
and, and by the way, again, just, you
know, full disclosure on one wheel,
I have a research group here at
Stanford, right? My recent career,
Stanford is one of the better
known researchers in the world.
But just don't join us because you think
we're well known, right? It's this,
it's just not a good reason to
join some of the brands. Instead,
you're only work with someone,
meet the people and evaluate
the individuals or look
at the people and see if
you think these are people you can
learn from a worker and a good people.
Okay.
So,
um,
so in today's world, there
are a lot of companies, um,
recruiting Stanford students.
So let me give you some advice.
In this piece of volume are good because
many as well, I just give the advice.
So sometimes there are giant
companies with let's say, um,
uh, uh, you know, 50,000 people, right?
And I'm not thinking of any one specific
company if you're trying to get so
confidence in golf, there's no one
specific company I'm thinking of,
but this pattern matches,
uh, to many large companies,
but maybe there's a giant company
with 50,000 people, right?
And that say that they have a 300 person,
right? Ai Team. Um,
it turns out that if you look at the
work of the few and depressing the I team
and if they send you a job offer
to join to 300% of the it team,
that might be pretty good, right? This
is, this may be a group, you know,
whose work you hear about their potions
papers. You really want a news. Um,
and so if you can a job offer to work
with this group that might be pretty good
or even better,
would be sometimes even within the 30%,
the Itm is actually difficult to
tell what's good and what's not.
There's often a lot of errands,
even with this was even better,
would be if you get a job offer
to join the 30 person team.
So you actually know who's your manager,
who your peers, who you're working with.
And if you think these are 30
great people you can learn from,
that could be a job offer on the
failure mode that unfortunately,
I've seen several Stanford students
go down there and say, actually,
this is a true story. Uh, there was ones,
uh, several years ago as a San Franciscan,
I knew that, I thought it was a great
guy. Right? You know, I, I knew his work.
He was Kodak machine
there in the outer rooms.
I thought he was very sharp
and did very good work. Uh,
working with some of my phd students.
He got a job offer from one of these
giant companies with that has a great AI
group.
Um,
and his Alpha wasn't to go to the AI group
is offer was to join us and there was
sign you to a team.
So this,
pick the student that was this emphasis
and I know about and the kind of care
about,
um,
he wound up being assigned to really
boring a Java or backend payments team.
And, uh, so after you set the job offer,
he wound up being assigned to a, you know,
back in and apologize Emma, you work on
Java backend payment processing systems.
I think they're great.
But the student was assigned to that
team and he was really bored. And so,
um, I think that this was a
student whose career I perceive,
so has career rising while he was at
Stanford and after he went to this,
frankly not very interesting team,
I saw his career plateau. Um,
and after about a year and a half,
he resigned from this company after
wasting a year and a half of his life and
missing out really on a year and a half
of this very exciting growth of AI and
machine learning. Right? So it does.
Very unfortunate. Um, uh, and, and Oh,
it was actually after I told this story
last time I taught this class earlier
this year that actually
someone from, um, uh,
actually was actually from the same big
company you felt Mina said by Andrea.
Wish she told me the story earlier because
this is exactly what happened to me
at the same big company.
Now I want to share with
you, uh, a different, um,
so, so I would just be careful about
rotation programs as well. You know,
when a company is trying to recruit you,
if a company refuses to tell
you what projects you work on,
who is your manager exactly what
team you're joining, I proceed.
Do not find those job offers that
attractive because, uh, it, the con,
you know,
if they refuse to tell you what team
are going to work with while chances are
right, tell me the answer will not
make the job attractive to you.
That's why they're not telling you.
So just be very careful.
And sometimes rotation programs sound
good on paper, but it's really, you know,
well,
we'll figure out where to send you later.
So I feel like I've seen some students
go into rotation programs that sound good
on paper.
That sounds like a good idea.
But just as you would in [inaudible]
Stanford would you want to do for
internships and then apply for a job,
there'll be a weird thing to do.
So sometimes rotation permits out,
Yo come and do for internships and they
will let you apply for a job and see
where we were when I sent you.
And it could be Java backend payment
processing system, right? So, um, uh,
so just, just be cautious about the
marketing of rotation programs. Oh,
and again, if you do, but if, but if they,
what they say is do rotation
and then you joined this team,
then you can look at this team
and say, Yep, that's a great team.
I want to do a rotation.
But then I would go and work with this
team and these are the 30 people worker.
So that could be great.
But during rotation,
then you could send you anywhere in this
giant company that I would just be very
careful if, all right.
Um, now on the flip side,
they're awesome companies and I'm
not going to mention any companies,
but there are some companies where
you though are not as glamorous. Now,
there's not as right cool brands.
Um,
and maybe this is a Oh
no 10,000 person company,
1000 or 50,000 per second or whatever,
unless it's 10,000 for a coffee.
I have seen many companies that are
not super well known in the AI world.
They're not in the news all the time,
but they may have a very elite team of
a hundred people doing great work in
machine learning. Right? And there are
definitely companies whose brands and not,
you know,
the first company you would think of
when you think of great AI companies, um,
that sometimes they have a really,
really great 10 person or 50 person,
a 100 person team that works under,
in the algorithms.
And even if the overall brand,
the overall company, you know,
isn't as like,
as a little bit sucky,
if you manage to track down this team
and if you have a job offer to join this
team in a much bigger company,
you could actually learn a lot from these
people and do important work. You know,
one of the things about
silicon valley is that, um,
the brand on your resume
matters lesson less, right?
Less than ever before. I mean,
I guess, Oh, I think, uh, uh, the
exception of the Stanford brand,
you're totally when the staff of
grounded resume, but with that exception,
they're really, your silicon valley's
become really good. Sorry, the, the world,
right? It has become really
good at evaluating people
for your genuine technical
schools and your genuine capability
and less for your brands. Um,
and so I would recommend that instead
of trying to get the best stamps of
approval on your resume to
go and tick the positions,
they let you have the best learning
experiences and also allows you to do the
most important work. And that has
really shaped by the, you know,
30 or 50 people you work with and not
by the overall brand of the company you
work with. Right. So the
variants across, um, uh,
so there's a huge variance
across teams within one company,
and that variance is actually
pretty bigger or might be
bigger than the veterans
across different companies does
make sense. So, so I would,
and if a company refuses to
tell you what team you rejoin,
I would seriously consider just, you know,
doing so if you have a better option,
I would do something else.
Um, and then finally,
um, yeah, and, and so really, I, again, I,
I guess I don't want to name
these companies, but you know,
think of some of the large retailers or
some of the large healthcare systems or
the lot of companies, uh, that are
not well known in the Ai World,
but that I've met the AI teams.
I think they're great.
And so if you're able to find
those jobs and meet their people,
you can actually get very
exciting jobs in here, right? Oh,
but up cost for the giant companies
that Evie I teams you can join that Uva,
the my aunt. That's also,
that's also a great,
I'm a bit biased since I used
to lead some of these team. So,
so I think those things are great, but
that's a, but also some teams in the, um,
uh, yeah. All right. Um,
lost sleep, you know, just general advice.
This is how I really live my life. Um,
I tend to choose the things to work on.
They'll allow you to
learn the most. Um, you know,
we tried to do important work,
so, you know, especially if you're
a relative, the early in career,
whether have you learn the, your career
will pay off for a long time. And so,
um, uh, uh, and so joining the teams,
they're working with a great set of 10
or 30 or 50 teammates will let you learn
a lot. Um, and then also,
you know, hopefully, I mean,
yeah. And, and, and uh, and,
and just don't, don't, don't join,
uh, like a sacred company and hope,
you know, give more people cancer or
stuff like that. Or is this, don't,
don't do this, don't do stuff like that.
But if you can do meaningful worth,
it helps other people and
do important work, uh, uh,
and also learn a lot on the way. Hopefully
you can find positions site that, that,
that, that lets you set, set
yourself up for long term success.
We'll also do work that you think
matters and that it helps other people.
All right. Um, any
questions before we wrap up?
What's important?
You know,
I think one of the most meaningful things
to do in life is help other people,
uh, either advance the human
condition or help other people.
But the thing is I'm nervous.
I don't want to name one or two things
because the world needs a lot of people
who work in a lot of different things.
So the world's not going to function if
everyone works on computational biology.
I think con bio is great,
but it's actually good that where people
work on come bio. My Phd students like,
you know, uh, many work on
the outside to healthcare. Uh,
my team at landing AI does a lot of
work on the outside to manufacturing to
every culture, to some health care
and some other industries. Um, uh,
I actually, especially the
California fires burning, you know,
I actually think that there's important
work to be done in AI and climate change.
Uh, um, but I think that, uh,
there's a log of them important
work and a lot of industries, right?
So I should think that,
you know,
I actually think that the
next wave of Ai sees me,
I should say machine learning
is with, we've already, um,
transform a lot of the tech
world. Right? Uh, uh, so,
you know, yeah. I mean,
we've already helped a lot of the second
valley tech world become cadet AI and
that's fate, right? Help build a cover
of the teams. They wound up doing this,
right? Google brain. How Google become
good. The deep learning, the, by the way,
I grew up hop, I do become, you
know, good at one of the greatest,
the I companies in the world. So the in
China. Um, and I'm very happy that, uh,
between me and some of my
friends in the industry,
we've made a lot of good AI companies.
I think part of the next phase for the
evolution of machine learning is Fred to
go into not just the tech companies like,
you know, like the Google and Baidu,
which I hoped as well as, you
know, Facebook, Microsoft,
which had nothing to do with as well as,
um, what else? Airbnb, Pinterest, Rubella,
right? All these are great companies.
I hope they're all embrace AI,
but I think some of the most
exciting work to be done.
So it was also look outside the tech
industry, uh, and to look at all the,
sometimes call them traditional industries
that do not have shiny tech things
because I think the value
creation there as surprise,
you could implement there maybe even
bigger than if you, you know, uh,
uh, uh, yeah. Uh, actually I, I
mentioned one interesting thing.
One thing I notice is a lot
of the large tech companies,
I'll work on the same problems, right?
So everyone, we're a machine translation.
Every Ross speech recognition,
face detection at click through rate.
And part of me feels like this is
great because it means there's a lot of
progress in machine translation
and that's great. We do,
I'm proud of the machine translation.
But sometimes when you look at
other industries, um, so you know,
when the look at manufacturing or um,
uh,
some of the medical devices,
things working at odds or uh,
sometimes they'll on these farms
hanging out with farmers on, on, on, um,
few like in my own work and my teams
where sometimes we're stumbling across
brand new research problems that the big
tech companies do not see and have not
yet learned to frame.
So find one of the most intellectually
exciting challenges is actually you to be
constantly on the cutting age, uh,
looking at these types of problems.
There's a different cutting edge than
the containers, the big tech companies.
So I think some of you are joining the
big tech companies and that's great.
We need more AI and the big
companies in the tech companies.
But I think lot of exciting
work to do in AI is also, um,
outside what we traditionally
consider the tech. Great.
All right. US tent this
whole fifties. So, hope,
I hope this was helpful. Um, uh, and,
uh, let's, let's break, visit. Oh,
have a, have a great
thanksgiving, everyone,
and we'll see you in a couple of weeks.